Alexa you went and played for honor I
did I played a lot of for honor like two
hours all over two hours so that's more
than Lucy and snorted who we have they
have put up an impressions piece which
you can check out on youtube and
GameSpot as well yeah but you were there
with with the development team as well
talking to them so kind of want to talk
to you about that and Jason Vandenberg I
guess the lead on this project
interesting story about how he came up
with this oh my gosh he's so he's one of
the more interesting game developers
I've ever met he was explaining to me
that his wife bought him a like one year
membership to a German longsword Wow
dojo basically it's a commitment one
year yeah with like the armor which is
like the Association for Renaissance
martial arts in North America okay so he
was literally as he explained it walking
home one day thinking like it he's a
good a game designer for a long time
he's been at Ubisoft for like eight nine
years I think and he was thinking like
oh like what if I mapped how would this
stroke look like on a right analog stick
or how this stroke look how would that
be and he literally like built the game
thinking about like how would I map this
to a controller and then it came into a
game BR became a game and then he
pitched it and pitched it for like 13
years and finally Ubisoft Montreal said
yes any laughing for honor that's
incredible so presumably that's why
we're in this scenario where you have
combatants who wouldn't necessarily be
fighting each other in any sort of
real-world scenario but I guess they all
have their own fighting style they do
yeah it's definitely a game for like
weapon nerds and like fighting nerds
like when you think of a game like Dark
Souls where you're like oh I want the
power fantasy of wielding these giant
weapons like this power fantasy is a
little more a little closer to the
fantasy you could get there like doing
it in real life yeah but they have 12
characters and every single one has a
different weapon set and a different
different animations and a different
style of play which is absolutely
incredible how does it feel to play
because when I look at it and I was
listen to tomorrow and Lucy talk about
it as well is that it feels like there's
something clunky and difficult about
wielding a sword in the first place how
does the game sort of deal with that
because Maddie combats all other than
something games of like two struggled
with well it
it does a really good job of giving you
the tools to like back up if you need to
like you can cancel a heavy attack
halfway through something that I figured
out how to do the opposing team kept
falling for it I would go into my heavy
attack and they would go to block
because there's the triangle block
system or I can block or Perry or hit on
the top and the two sides so I'd go to
the left with my heavy and it would give
them a telegraph my move and it would
give them time to blah perfect but then
I would cancel and then do a light
attack and I flipped to the right side
and get them it does a really good job
of giving you the tools to do that
depending on what kind of fighter you
are also you could be like a big heavy
person with very little defense or you
could be a small quick person who maybe
doesn't our character who doesn't do a
lot of damage but moves much quickly
than your opponent so what it sort of
does is it encourages you when you're on
a team to choose together who will be
what and then right let each other play
to theirs play To Your Strengths and
depend on each other let's talk about
that team players well what a feels like
to fight in these big groups because
another thing that seemed to stand out
in the gameplay was that you know if you
sort of need to like maybe pirate you
know pile up with somebody like two on
one in his situation is going to be very
advantageous what does it feel like
working with other people and what does
it feel like working as a team and not
like war scenario so the developer told
us we were that we were the one of the
producers was guide sort of guiding us
through when he said best piece of
advice no matter what you do if you are
fighting someone and a second from the
other team and a second person comes up
don't try to take them on alone get out
of there because every time you die the
other team gets more points and writing
it more capture points so heard you to
not try and bite off more than you can
chew um and I expected I was sitting in
a row with like four other people a team
of four and I was expecting it to be
like like I played online games before
and it's sort of like in battlefront
it's like Oh guys like Palpatine's in
this room you never really tame like
it's really really calm we were like
guys guys I'm over here I'm going to a
know this guy behind me I'm running away
like i need help i need help like people
were talking and whenever we would
respawn it would be like okay like who
needs help who's doubling up but someone
would be like there's two bad guys and
be i need backup here is literally
we were constantly talking and no one
tried to be the hero no one tried to be
the guy that goes in and get all the
kills it was actually like we fell into
a very nice pattern of helping each
other because you're not just for honor
does a really good job of letting you
know that it's not this isn't about you
this is about you as a team right like
you'd live and die together and so much
is riding on how you work with each
other and how you capture and it was
very very exhilarating and very tense
like there's a feature where if you if
you get a certain number of points it
locks the other team from respawning
right so you have you have to kill all
four of them but you have to kill a for
them before they capture any of the
other capture points yeah cool I was
like a rallying yeah under the bottle
and you all have to band together and be
like okay like we got it we gotta knock
them down so we'll send two to one guy
to another guy maybe leave one place
vulnerable just to get get someone out
and it's a it's very tense like my palms
are very sweaty by the end of that match
yeah we could sit here and talk about
this all day thankfully you've written a
massive a preview which is available on
gamespot com so if you want to learn
more about for honor the game that is
coming out on playstation 4 xbox one and
pc on februari 14 with lucy said just
the times for Valentine's Day next year
if you want to learn more about that
please go to gamespot com
you